hey have you ever seen this kind of
plant before it's called a dandelion if
you live in a tropical climate it might
be unfamiliar but if you live in a more
temperate zone you'll probably recognize
it as it's a very common plant
dandelions make yellow flowers that
develop into balls of these fluffy white
seed heads that fly off the plant this
can happen by a gust of wind by animals
spreading them or even by someone
blowing on the plant
when this happens its seeds fly into the
air and land on new spots on the ground
from there the seeds can grow into new
dandelions starting the whole cycle over
but why do dandelions do this
why do they turn into puff balls why are
they yellow
if they don't have brains how do they
seem to know when to release their seeds
these are all complicated questions
but to begin answering them we can talk
about what influences the growth and
development of dandelions and in turn
all living things
so what determines how our dandelion
will grow
its genes and its environment
let's take a moment to review what genes
are
genes make up the hereditary material
inside an organism's cells
genes provide the information about what
traits an organism has so
the reason that our dandelion has yellow
petals and develops fluffy white seed
heads lies within its genes
any influence genes have on the way an
organism grows is called a genetic
factor
so if one dandelion has more seeds than
another as a result of which version of
a certain gene it has we can say that
the difference in seed number is due to
a genetic factor
the other major influence on how our
dandelion grows is its environment
but what makes up an organism's
environment
the environment is the set of conditions
an organism is exposed to during its
life
for our dandelion this includes
temperature how much light and water it
gets and which nutrients are present in
the soil where it grows
any influence the environment has on an
organism's growth is called an
environmental factor
so if one dandelion plant is exposed to
more sunlight than another and grows
bigger as a result we can say that the
difference is due to an environmental
factor
but plants aren't the only living
organisms that are motivated by these
factors
animals are also influenced by their
genes and environment
for example let's look at dogs
dogs come in many different shapes sizes
colors and each have their own unique
features we can see this when looking at
different breeds like pugs which are
small with squishy faces and golden
retrievers which are large with flowing
locks of golden fur
these traits are largely determined by
which genes each breed of dog has or in
other words by genetic factors
but dogs are also influenced by
environmental factors too for instance
how much food they get as they grow
helps determine their size
and what they learn from other dogs and
from people help determine their
behaviors like when you teach your dog a
new trick
and now you know how organisms are
influenced by genetics and their
environment when it comes to growth and
development
let's do a quick review of what you've
learned today
first there are two main factors that
influence an organism's growth these are
genetic and environmental factors
genetic factors are the genes the
organism gets from its parent or parents
while environmental factors are the
conditions an organism is exposed to as
it grows these factors show that all
living organisms have a couple things in
common
even dogs and dandelions so while our
interactions with them may differ like
how you can't teach a dandelion to sit
like you can with a dog
both organisms experience growth and
development through their own unique
genes and environments